you've got to be so sick of me by now no
it's great always great talking to you
that was a great uh panel we had there
wasn't that wonderful I thought it was
so good I thought that was our best one
yeah it was exciting it felt like I was
in celebration there were so many people
there who were so excited to see what we
were showing and they see most of them
they'd seen that episode already yeah so
is the panel and you were our uh your
anchor there yeah it was great it was
awesome we had Pedro and we had uh Rick
famuyua yeah and uh
that's right Katie sack off we had and
then Dave it was really cool it was a
nice it was a nice it was a nice
experience there I think they really
liked it and there you were it was a big
big theater there I know
crazy four balconies there's the
thousands of people in there it was
great we've been through this uh you
know since the beginning yeah just in
this capacity but on stage together and
a celebration together here you are
across the pond you travel all the way
here no how are you I'm sorry I'm jet
lag too I'm a little jet-lagged yeah I
woke up at four in the morning and just
could not go back to sleep yeah are you
building any new coins because I have
two yes what do you have I have Boba
Fett and Mandalorian DeLorean yeah I had
those those there's a there are some
others in the works the Skeleton Crew in
the works looking pretty cool and uh but
I I can't speak to anything else it's a
I don't want to say it seems that even a
coin's a spoiler now in Star Wars yeah
maybe I really don't yeah really keep it
I was trained not to say anything about
anything
um I one of my predictions for this
panel and I'm so excited was announced
is that Dave filoni is directing a
freaking Star Wars movie yeah yeah right
are you guys like culminating to that
movie that's like the sense I think well
yeah the thing is like when now that you
have so many media to choose from you
have to make sure that the story is
appropriate for the medium right so
not everything wants to get jammed into
an hour and a half two hour movie some
stories want to be told over many many
episodes right like the Clone Wars or
like what we do in the Mandalorian so
but then you also can get a lot of scope
and scale and you just an experience
that you can't really get it home from
from a film like that so we just want to
make sure that the story drives
everything but what I'm I'm really
excited about is that Dave filoni and
the time that I've collaborated with him
has been from him being an anime you
know heading up the animation for clone
wars and me doing a voice
to us showing each other what we're
working on at the Skywalker Ranch or the
Iron Man and Clone Wars when that was
before the either of them were out
and then working on this together being
paired up by Kathy and and and his first
being around for the first time he ever
directed live action to all the way
through all the different
um you know episodes that he had worked
on and then also like even when he's not
directing we're in the editing room
together we're looking he's learning
about this medium and how to apply all
of his storytelling uh abilities and
skills that he learned from George and
on his own
and now finally with Ahsoka which is you
know this scale and scope is you know
really ambitious and just him as a
live-action Storyteller and now it's
like you know where everybody's looking
we're looking at each other Kathy myself
people at Disney
it's like this is he's the right guy to
do it and you know paid his dues with it
understands the characters the
storytelling and has the skill so uh
that gets me really excited and how
could I be there for him in this
capacity producing with him and you know
working on the script and and figuring
out you know how does this fit into all
the other narratives that are happening
in this time frame I felt in the panel
my biggest takeaway is like I just felt
the dots really connect because you've
got like mon mothma shows up in the
Ahsoka trailer and you've got a certain
person that's mentioned in the footage
we saw from the Mandalorian it's just
it's all connecting now yeah it's really
fun because a lot of this is stuff we
knew was going here and it's interesting
when you do week by week people are
watching like what's going on who's that
how's that you know and and uh and it's
like this sort of half a version of it
happens every season and I think this
one because the story is becoming so
expansive so all-encompassing of all the
things that we built up to this point
and uh and so it's it's for us it's fun
to to have that much runway to bring it
into it and how can we you know resolve
all the things we set up and and also
because the television where does it go
from here how do you so these these next
couple weeks are going to be really fun
to for us to see how people
react and connect with with you know all
this work that we've done
foreign